You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥，但我们还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路的了！或者你可以预订希尔顿的房间。欢迎来到您的海滨客房，距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Reading is a skill that many of us take for granted, but for millions of children and adults, it can be a daily struggle. Dislexia is one of the most common learning differences,
希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿App上预订，最高可省20%，享受符合期望的住宿。当您想要省钱而不是惊喜时，您在哪里入住至关重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。阅读是许多人视为理所当然的一项技能，但对于数百万儿童和成人来说，这可能是每天的挣扎。读写困难是最常见的学习差异之一，
potentially affecting up to one in five people, yet it's still widely misunderstood and misdiagnosed. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies dyslexia and reading difficulties about the state of dyslexia science. What causes dyslexia? How is it diagnosed, and and how early can we identify it? What interventions work best to help people with dyslexia learn how to read? How to reading difficulties affect mental health? And what does the research say about how families, educators, and schools can best support struggling readers? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
可能影响多达五分之一的人，然而它仍然被广泛误解和误诊。今天我们将采访一位研究读写困难和阅读困难的心理学家，探讨读写困难科学的现状。是什么导致了读写困难？它是如何诊断的，我们最早能在什么时候识别它？哪些干预措施对帮助读写困难人群学习阅读最有效？阅读困难如何影响心理健康？关于家庭、教育工作者和学校如何最好地支持挣扎中的读者，研究是怎么说的？欢迎收看《心理学话语》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Tim Odegaard, a professor of psychology and the Catherine Davis-Murphy Chair of Excellence in Dyslexic Studies at Middle Tennessee State University. As a developmental cognitive psychologist, Dr. Odegaard studies how to identify struggling readers, what are the most effective intervention methods, and how can teachers help dyslexic students. He has written dozens of peer-reviewed articles and serves as editor-in-chief of the journal Analysts of Dyslexia. Dr. Odegaard also brings personal experience to this topic, having been diagnosed with dyslexia himself.
旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是蒂姆·奥德加德（Tim Odegaard）博士，他是中田纳西州立大学的心理学教授，也是凯瑟琳·戴维斯-墨菲（Catherine Davis-Murphy）读写困难研究卓越讲席教授。作为一名发展认知心理学家，奥德加德博士研究如何识别挣扎中的读者、最有效的干预方法是什么，以及教师如何帮助读写困难的学生。他撰写了数十篇同行评议的文章，并担任《读写困难分析》（Analysts of Dyslexia）杂志的主编。奥德加德博士也为这个话题带来了个人经验，因为他自己就被诊断出患有读写困难。
Dr. Odegaard, thank you for joining me today. Thanks, Kim. I'm really glad to be here today with you. You've written and spoken about your own experience with dyslexia, and I'd like to start there. Tell us what it was like learning to read for you and how do those early experiences influence the work you're doing today? Well, learning to read for me was extremely difficult, and it's also important to highlight that spelling is a real challenge for those of us with dyslexia as well. So reading and writing are really challenging. Dislexia earth really emerges in the early grades. So for me, when I was in the readers, it was fairly straightforward when I was able to listen to other children and the teacher
奥德加德博士，感谢您今天加入我。谢谢，金。我很高兴今天能和你在一起。你曾撰文并谈到过自己患有读写困难的经历，我想从那里开始。请告诉我们，对你来说学习阅读是什么样的，这些早期经历如何影响你今天的工作？嗯，对我来说学习阅读极其困难，同样重要的是要强调，对于我们这些有读写困难的人来说，拼写也是一个真正的挑战。所以阅读和写作确实很有挑战性。读写困难确实在低年级就显现出来了。所以对我来说，当我还在读低年级的时候，事情还算直接，当我能够听其他孩子和老师
read words and a limited number of them, memorize those, and masquerade as if I was really reading and pronouncing those words. I understood the book if I heard it read to me, but it was really hard for me to pronounce the words. So I really masqueraded for quite a while until it really became apparent that I wasn't able to read the words for myself and I was really memorizing them. It's a strategy that many of us used to kind of hide in the distance in the background until we're uncovered. So it definitely started in third grade where my formal testing happened. And unfortunately, because of the method used at the time when I was being identified, I never got a formal diagnosis of dyslexia. They knew I couldn't read very well. But my IQ,
朗读单词以及数量有限的单词，把它们记住，并伪装得好像我真的在阅读和发音那些单词一样。如果有人读给我听，我能听懂这本书，但要我自己发音那些单词真的很难。所以我确实伪装了相当长的一段时间，直到明显看出我无法自己阅读这些单词，而其实只是在死记硬背。这是我们许多人用来在背景中隐藏一段时间直到被揭穿的策略。所以它绝对是从三年级开始的，当时我进行了正式测试。不幸的是，由于当时鉴别时使用的方法，我从未得到读写困难的正式诊断。他们知道我读不好书。但我的智商，
testing was way too low. So the model that was being used at the time, the IQ discrepancy limited what I was able to do. So that was kind of my early childhood was struggling, getting the testing, thinking that help would be on the way and then actually being denied the services through the IDEA federal regulations here in the United States. Let me back up a minute. You said your IQ was much too low. Don't you mean your IQ was high and your reading comprehension was the problem? No, actually. So that's a good way of highlighting that. In the discrepancy model, what you want to find is somebody who has an IQ that suggests their potential, a way of measuring a person's potential in the United States in particular
测试得分太低了。所以当时使用的模型，智商差异限制了我的能力。这就是我早年童年挣扎的经历，接受测试，以为帮助就在路上，但实际上在美国的IDEA联邦法规下被拒绝提供服务。让我倒回一分钟。你说你的智商太低了。难道你的意思是你的智商很高，而阅读理解才是问题所在？不，其实不是。所以这是一个很好的强调方式。在差异模型中，你想找的是一个智商表明其潜力的人，一种衡量一个人潜力的方法，特别是在美国，
for a long time, is high enough to say that we're really going to be able to achieve more than what we're showing in an academic area. For me, it was reading and spelling. They knew that my reading and spelling was well below average, but my IQ test wasn't that high in the average range. So when you looked at the difference, there wasn't a big enough span. So the logic at the time was, is if we're not able to perform on this one test and IQ test high enough to show that we have greater potential, then what we're experiencing are expected underachievement. It was expected that I would struggle with reading because my intelligence wasn't high enough to allow me to do more. I see. Now, for our listeners who are new to this topic, can you briefly explain
很长一段时间以来，这个潜力高到足以说明我们在学术领域实际取得的成绩将超过我们所展示的。对我来说，那是阅读和拼写。他们知道我的阅读和拼写远远低于平均水平，但我的智商测试并没有那么高，没有达到平均水平。所以当你看到这种差距时，跨度不够大。当时的逻辑是，如果我们在这个单一测试——智商测试上表现不够高，无法显示我们有更大的潜力，那么我们所经历的就是预期的学业落后。预计我会与阅读挣扎，因为我的智商不够高，无法让我做得更多。我明白了。现在，对于刚接触这个话题的听众，你能简要解释一下
what dyslexia is? I mean, are most reading difficulties? to dyslexia or is it just one thing among many that can cause reading problems? It's one thing among many. We've now really identified that dyslexia is in this pantheon of language-based learning differences. And what dyslexia really impacts is there's a select few of us who have challenges with reading and spelling words accurately, developing efficiency with reading individual words, and that will then impede our ability to read text fluently. So at the basic literacy skills level we really show up and are identified. This typically is something that comes up early because it's in the most basic skills in reading and writing, so reading words and spelling
什么是读写困难吗？我的意思是，大多数阅读困难都与读写困难有关，还是说这只是导致阅读问题的众多原因之一？这是众多原因中的一个。我们现在真正认识到，读写困难属于基于语言的学习差异这一范畴。读写困难真正影响的是，我们当中有少数人很难准确阅读和拼写单词，在阅读单个单词时缺乏效率，这进而会阻碍我们流利阅读文本的能力。因此，在基础读写技能水平上，我们确实表现出来并被识别。这通常是一个较早出现的问题，因为它涉及阅读和写作中最基本的技能，所以阅读单词和拼写
words that we show our deficits. But there are other challenges with language learning that really can present in different ways and cause different types of outcomes. And it's not uncommon for those of us who struggle to read and spell words to also have issues with other things, larger language differences. Developmental language disability is one of those types of differences. There's a high co-occurrence of kids who struggle to understand how we put words together to make meaningful utterances, phrases, and sentences and paragraphs, as well as how to comprehend the language on the more general level, the oral language. Is there any connection between dyslexia and the ability to read numerals? I mean, if you can't distinguish letters, can you still distinguish numbers?
单词正是我们表现出缺陷的地方。但语言学习中还有其他挑战，确实会以不同的方式呈现并导致不同类型的结果。对于我们这些在阅读和拼写单词方面有困难的人来说，同时出现其他问题（即更大范围的语言差异）并不罕见。发育性语言障碍就是这些差异之一。许多孩子在理解我们如何将单词组合成有意义的言语、短语、句子和段落方面，以及如何在更一般水平（即口语）上理解语言方面存在困难，这些孩子之间存在高度的共患率。读写困难与阅读数字的能力之间有什么联系吗？我的意思是，如果你分不清字母，你还能分清数字吗？
That's a good question. So there is a link between dyslexia and the ability to do math, but it's not necessarily on those numerals. Since the primary driver of dyslexia has not been identified to be a visual-based one, learning numbers is isolated units and being able to distinguish those is not typically a challenge for those of us. I'm a good case of example. For something else you might think would be a challenge, which is learning to read musical
这是一个好问题。所以读写困难与做数学的能力之间存在联系，但并不一定体现在这些数字上。由于读写困难的主要驱动因素尚未被确定为基于视觉的因素，因此将数字作为孤立单位来学习并能够区分它们，对我们来说通常不是挑战。我就是一个很好的例子。对于你可能认为具有挑战性的其他事情，比如学习阅读音乐
notation because I'm a musician and I went to college on a music scholarship and I play multiple instruments. That was not a challenge for me. So that's kind of a misnomer out there that it might be challenging for us to do numbers or even learn how to read music because it's often thought that we see letters backwards, but that is actually a myth that's been out there. What we often have is limited exposure to print text. And when you have limited exposure to text, it delays your ability to develop the visual representations to see those letters and see them properly. So we're just developmentally delayed in that. The real nexus seems to be in how we process language as one of the primary drivers very early in life. We can find those types of things with us. What do we know about
符号，因为我是一名音乐家，我是靠音乐奖学金上的大学，而且我会演奏多种乐器。这对我和我来说不是挑战。所以外面有一种误解，认为我们在处理数字甚至学习识谱时可能会遇到困难，因为人们常常认为我们把字母看反了，但这其实是一个流传已久的迷思。我们通常面对的是对印刷文本接触有限的情况。而当你接触文本有限时，就会延迟你发展视觉表征以看到这些字母并正确看到它们的能力。所以我们只是在发育上有所延迟。真正的症结似乎在于我们很早就将语言处理作为生命中非常早期的主要驱动因素之一。我们可以在自己身上发现这些类型的事情。我们对
what's going on in the brain that causes dyslexia? I mean, if you do an fMRI of a person with dyslexia, does their brain look different? It does. I've actually done some of the original research in this area with my own brain imaging research and others, and that's continued. We typically say that it's the left language centers in the brain that show underactivation, as well as a lack of interconnectivity, kind of functioning as a network, if you will. We used to think that we knew kind of a lot about it in the sense of like, it clearly looks like this is a signature. It does have like a neurobiological predisposition that can increase the likelihood that we present. We find that through genetic studies, but most importantly, family risk studies.
大脑中导致读写困难的原因了解多少？我的意思是，如果你对一个有读写困难的人进行功能性磁共振成像（fMRI），他们的大脑看起来会不同吗？确实如此。我实际上用我自己的脑成像研究和其他研究在这一领域做了一些最初的研究，并且这种研究一直在继续。我们通常说，是大脑左侧的语言中心表现出激活不足，以及缺乏互联性（如果你愿意的话，可以将其视为作为一个网络运作）。我们过去认为我们在某种意义上对它了解很多，因为它显然看起来像是一个特征。它确实具有神经生物学上的易感性，可以增加我们表现出这种状况的可能性。我们通过遗传学研究发现了这一点，但最重要的是，通过家族风险研究。
Having a first-degree relative to dyslexia is a really strong risk factor. But the brain signature really is one that we're still grappling with what it means. Some of the most important work in here was done by a colleague of mine, Nadine Gob, as well as Ola Ozenoff-Palcheck up at Harvard at MIT. And what they were really showing is even before you are in school, even before kindergarten, kids at high family risk will show specific differences in brain structure as well as brain function. And those differences at three and four will actually predict a child's later ability to read words accurately and efficiently. So we do know that there's a brain basis. What we think we used to
有一位患有读写困难的一级亲属是一个非常强烈的风险因素。但大脑特征确实是一个我们仍在努力理解其含义的领域。其中一些最重要的工作是由我的同事娜丁·加布（Nadine Gaab）以及哈佛和麻省理工学院的奥拉·奥泽诺夫-帕尔切克（Ola Ozernov-Palchik）完成的。他们真正展示的是，甚至在你上学之前，甚至在幼儿园之前，具有高家族风险的儿童就会在脑结构和脑功能上表现出特定的差异。而三四岁时的这些差异实际上可以预测儿童日后准确、高效阅读单词的能力。所以我们确实知道存在大脑基础。我们认为我们以前
know about is architecture and what it looks like has really been reshaked by modern neuroimaging. I said in the intro that dyslexia may affect up to 20% of people. Is that, accurate and is that number changing over time? I mean, it seems to me that we have better diagnostics than we had. When I was a kid, I mean, there was nothing called dyslexia. We didn't know that at all. So the kid couldn't read. You know, the kid was thought to be not very bright. Right. And that's actually one of the misnomer's that we try to dispel with the term dyslexia, which is a person can be bright or exceptionally bright and still struggle to read and spell words. The 20% prevalence rate really depends on how you decide where to cut and determine the severity that you expect someone to present with and the
了解的关于大脑架构及其外观的知识，已经被现代神经成像技术彻底重塑了。我在引言中说过，读写困难可能会影响多达20%的人。这个数字准确吗，而且这个数字随时间在变化吗？我的意思是，在我看来，我们的诊断水平比以前提高了。当我还是个孩子的时候，根本没有什么叫读写困难的东西。我们根本不知道这一点。所以孩子不会读书。你知道的，人们认为这个孩子不太聪明。对的。这其实正是我们试图通过“读写困难”这个词来消除的误解之一，即一个人可以很聪明或异常聪明，却依然在阅读和拼写单词时遇到困难。20%的患病率实际上取决于你如何决定从哪里切断并确定你期望某人表现出的严重程度以及
identification model. The challenge with dyslexia is, like with many conditions, is it's on a severity. We're talking to people about psychological science and psychology. Mental health is on a severity. Your depression can be major depression. You could have dyshthymia, which is just to say a mild form of depression. We often forget that even in the DSM-5 are, you know, the diagnostic manual for mental health, we're dealing with spectrum conditions or continuum conditions that are on a continuum. So I like to say that because sometimes people will use what I'm about to say kind of against the term of dyslexia. It's on a continuum of severity, just like many conditions are that we consider. We often identify it as a discrete category, meaning either you have dyslexia or you don't
识别模型。读写困难面临的挑战，和许多疾病一样，在于它是分严重程度的。我们正在和人们谈论心理学科学和心理学。心理健康也是分严重程度的。你的抑郁可能是重度抑郁。你可能会患有心境恶劣，也就是轻度抑郁。我们常常忘记，甚至在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中，也就是心理健康的诊断手册中，我们处理的也是谱系状况或连续体状况，它们是位于一个连续体上的。我喜欢这样说，因为有时人们会把我接下来要说的话用来反对“读写困难”这个词。它位于严重程度的连续体上，就像我们所考虑的许多疾病一样。我们经常将其识别为一个离散的类别，这意味着要么你有读写困难，要么你没有
have dyslexia. What that presents is a challenge, which is in the school day setting or a private practice with a neuropsychologist or a clinical psychologist or some other professional who can do identification, we think that we're going to come up with a black or white determination. But how severe you want the child's reading and spelling difficulties to be and how you identify them will really determine what the prevalence is. And so we can be anywhere from three to five percent if we come in and actually look at who doesn't respond well to intervention and are really persistently poor responders, that's about 3 to 5% of the population. Or if we come into a population and we look in a school-based setting across a district or a state or even a region as I've done in my
读写困难。这带来的挑战是，在学校日常环境中，或者在神经心理学家、临床心理学家的私人诊所里，或者在其他能够进行识别的专业人员那里，我们以为我们会得出非黑即白的判定。但是，你希望孩子的阅读和拼写困难达到多严重的程度，以及你如何识别他们，将真正决定患病率是多少。因此，如果我们介入并实际观察那些对干预反应不佳且属于持续反应不佳者的人，这个比例大约占总人口的3到5%。或者，如果我们进入一个群体，在一个学区、一个州甚至是我在我的
research, we might find as many as 20 or even more kids who are struggling with word reading and spelling. It's all about how we define it and how we set the threshold for who we're going to say categorically has a specific learning disability of reading that we call dyslexia. And I think that's true of many other conditions. And so it shouldn't be used as ammunition to say that somehow dyslexia is not real. Otherwise, depression is not real because depression also is on a continuum. Right. Well, let's talk about how dyslexia is diagnosed.
研究中所做的那样跨地区的学校环境中进行观察，我们可能会发现多达20%甚至更多的孩子在单词阅读和拼写方面挣扎。这完全取决于我们如何定义它，以及我们如何为我们要在范畴上说其患有我们称之为读写困难的特定阅读学习障碍设定门槛。我认为这对于许多其他疾病也是如此。因此，它不应被用作弹药，说某种程度上读写困难不是真的。否则抑郁症也不是真的，因为抑郁症也处于一个连续体上。好吧，让我们谈谈如何诊断读写困难。
You've written about a long history of problems with diagnosis that have left many people failing to get the services that they need. And often those are people with less privilege to begin with. Can you talk about where we are today in terms of identifying people, young people with dyslexia? Correct. I've identified historically that on average, even independent of those challenges, we've had issues with an under-identification, especially in Texas, for example, where I reported that the number of students being identified with dyslexia under state law there was zero, which is really important because there's been kind of a mispresentation of the dyslexia being really
你曾撰文指出，诊断方面存在着一段长期的历史问题，导致许多人未能获得他们所需的服务。通常，这些人原本就缺乏特权。你能谈谈我们今天在识别年轻的读写困难人群方面处于什么位置吗？没错。我历史上曾指出，平均而言，即使抛开这些挑战不谈，我们也一直存在识别不足的问题，尤其是在德克萨斯州，例如，我曾报道过，在该州州法律下被识别出患有读写困难的学生人数为零，这真的很重要，因为一直有一种对读写困难的虚假陈述，即它被
way over-identified and actually being misclassified away from other categories. My published research on this looking at actual state record shows that on average a few years ago, there were only zero kids on a high school campus that were being identified with dyslexia. So it's a real challenge for all children. This isn't just like a black or brown problem or a rich or poor problem. And that's really pushed this upspring in advocacy and legislation around dyslexia Roman country because it's really a global issue that affects all of us. Some of the challenges we've experienced is it's hard to identify who really has something
大大过度识别，并且实际上被错误分类，从其他类别中转移出去了。我对此发表的研究，通过查看实际的州记录显示，平均而言在几年前，高中校园里只有零个孩子被识别出患有读写困难。所以这对所有孩子来说都是一个真正的挑战。这不仅仅是一个黑人或棕色人种的问题，也不是一个富裕或贫穷的问题。这确实推动了全国各地围绕读写困难的倡导和立法浪潮，因为这确实是一个影响我们所有人的全球性问题。我们经历的一些挑战是，很难区分谁真正拥有
that you would call a disability versus the context they're in. Since we have such a challenge in many contexts with a lot of kids struggling to read and spell words, some of my research that I've also published shows it up to 65% and some underperforming poor schools. Some of these schools are almost predominantly white schools sometimes, or they could be a mixture of different ethnic groups. This is really a problem for all. It really makes it challenging for teachers. Who are you going to say are the even 20% of those kids at the upper limit who have dyslexia
你可以称之为残疾的状况，还是仅仅是他们所处的环境造成的。由于在许多情况下，许多孩子在阅读和拼写单词方面都面临巨大挑战，我发表的一些研究也表明，在一些表现不佳的贫困学校中，这一比例高达65%。其中一些学校有时几乎主要是白人学校，或者它们可能是不同族群的混合体。这确实是所有人面临的问题。这确实给老师带来了挑战。当你班上大多数学生都无法阅读和拼写单词时，你怎么能说甚至连那20%处于上限的、患有读写困难的孩子是谁呢？
when the majority of your students can't read and spell words? So an identification in a sea of struggling readers is one challenge that I've talked about highlighted, that if we don't get basic literacy right in the early grades, it creates this upper elementary middle and high school problem of so many kids are struggling that we can't identify the exceptional ones who have this difference that set them up to struggle to begin with. That's one challenge. Context matters. Second, the identification model you use also matters.
因此，在充满挣扎的阅读者的海洋中进行识别，是我所探讨和强调的一个挑战：如果我们不能在低年级打好基础读写能力，就会造成高年级小学、初中和高中的问题，即太多的孩子都在挣扎，以至于我们无法识别出那些原本就注定会挣扎的、具有这种差异的优秀孩子。这是一个挑战。环境很重要。其次，你使用的识别模型也很重要。
I grew up poor in white in a family that was blue collar. So I didn't perform well in an IQ test for real reasons. My vocabulary and my language development wasn't necessarily an enriched environment with college educated parents around me to support me for doing well in that test. And so when we take an IQ index as an indicator of who will and will not qualify for services for dyslexia, a form of a specific learning disability, then it really sets up kind of a discrepancy between who will and who will not, the haves and have not for that category. So that's a challenge.
我在一个蓝领家庭里贫穷地长大，我是白人。所以我没有在智商测试中表现好，这是有真正原因的。我的词汇量和语言发展并不一定处于一个有大学毕业的父母在我周围支持我在这项测试中取得好成绩的丰富环境中。因此，当我们把智商指数作为谁将符合或不符合读写困难服务（特定学习障碍的一种形式）资格的指标时，它确实在谁能得到和谁不能得到之间——也就是该类别的拥有者和没有者之间——造成了一种差异。所以这是一个挑战。
Then another model that's been used is that, well, we put them in really good instruction and we see who responds or who are the persistently poor responders. We're going to use what we call the instructional discrepancy. We put everybody in good core instruction for English language learning, how to read it, write, it, spell it, and understand it. We see who is struggling to learn those skills. And from those kids, we'll flag those who are going to come out and are going to be tiered up for getting intervention and a label of a specific learning disability like dyslexia. The challenge there is, is that we're struggling across the United States to actually implement English arts really, really well in schools. and when we struggle with teaching reading,
然后使用的另一个模型是，好吧，我们把他们置于非常好的教学中，看看谁有反应，谁是持续反应不佳者。我们将使用我们所谓的教学差异。我们让每个人都参与针对英语语言学习、如何阅读、写作、拼写和理解的良好核心教学。我们看看谁在学习这些技能时遇到困难。从这些孩子中，我们将挑选出那些将脱颖而出、将被分层提供干预以及获得特定学习障碍（如读写困难）标签的人。这里的挑战在于，我们在全美范围内都难以真正在学校里非常、非常好地实施英语艺术教学，而当我们难以教授阅读时，
then we create the disconnect between our ability to use an effective identification model based on instructional discrepancy to find kids. What that does is it pushes those of us who know better and can do better and have the resources to go outside of the school, and we get psychologists, diagnosticians, and others to do independent testing. We come back into the schools and we say, look, my kid can't read. They're struggling. They're way behind.
然后这就造成了脱节，我们无法根据教学差异使用有效的识别模型来寻找儿童。这样做的结果是，那些明白更好做法、有能力且有资源的人会选择校外途径，我们请来心理学家、诊断师和其他专家进行独立测试。当我们回到学校时就会说，看，我的孩子不会阅读。他们在挣扎。他们落后得很远。
They've been showing up to school. What are we going to do with it? This looks like they have a disability of some type. So you can see that there's really some challenges that we present kind of across the board. And what I want to highlight is, elevating instruction for all across all schools is going to create the context we need to identify those of us who are set up to struggle and need more instruction intervention to begin with. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Odegaard about early signs of dyslexia and whether warning signs can be identified even before children begin to learn to read.
他们一直都有去上学。我们要拿这个怎么办？这看起来像是某种类型的残疾。所以你可以看到，我们在各个方面确实都存在一些挑战。我想强调的是，在所有学校中全面提升教学水平，将为我们创造所需的环境，从而识别出那些天生容易遇到困难、从一开始就需要更多教学干预的儿童。我们要进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与奥德加德博士谈谈阅读障碍的早期迹象，以及在儿童开始学习阅读之前是否就能识别出警示信号。
It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees, Google FiWireless is not subject to data
现在是传粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩展。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂窝网络非常繁忙，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这绝对是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。不含税费和政府规费，Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷期间
traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price is invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions of
不会遭遇数据降速。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。还可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove 七件套户外餐饮桌椅尽情招待一整季，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不含
see homedepot.com slash price match for details. How early can dyslexia be identified? Are there signs as soon as kids start learning to read, or does it manifest even earlier than that? That's a great question. The answer to that is yes and, and I won't explain that yes. One of the challenges we have is how we define dyslexia
详情请参见 homedepot.com/price-match。阅读障碍最早可以在什么时候被识别出来？在孩子们刚开始学习阅读时就会有迹象，还是在更早的时候就已经表现出来了？这是一个很好的问题。这个问题的答案是“是的”而且“还有”，我来解释一下这个“是的”。我们面临的挑战之一是我们如何定义阅读障碍
will always be with its primary characteristics. Again, if we go to that tome called the DSM-5, you're going to open it up, and there will be a list of symptomatology, right, what it's supposed to look like. And there's normally like five to seven things. That's really important because if you're not manifesting those, you might have like a predisposition neurobiologically for something,
它将始终与其主要特征相伴。同样，如果我们翻阅那本名为《DSM-5》（精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版）的大部头，翻开它，就会看到一份症状列表，对吧，也就是它应该表现出来的样子。通常会有五到七项。这真的很重要，因为如果你没有表现出这些症状，你可能在神经生物学上对某种情况有某种倾向，
but you may not actually present the symptoms. What we know is we can find risk of dyslexia really early. I highlighted something earlier. A first degree relative with dyslexia is a high risk indicator that it might be difficult for you to struggle with reading and spelling later on in life. That means at conception, we know if a person's at an increased risk to struggle with that ability. The challenge is, until we get into formal schooling and we're now expected to be able to read and spell words, we can't struggle.
但你实际上可能并没有表现出症状。我们所知道的是，我们可以很早就发现患阅读障碍的风险。我刚才强调过一点。有一位患有阅读障碍的一级亲属，就是一个高风险指标，表明你在后期的生活和学习中可能会在阅读和拼写方面遇到困难。这意味着在受孕时，我们就知道一个人在这些能力上面临的挣扎风险是否增加。挑战在于，在我们进入正规学校教育、并被期望能够阅读和拼写单词之前，我们是不会显现出挣扎的。
So you can't present with the symptoms of dyslexia until you're expected to read and spell words, right? That makes sense. So until then, what we can do is we can find risk. Early general language abilities at two and three are another risk of two things. dyslexia, as well as symptoms of developmental language disability. So you can have more of a general broad language problem. And we've known this historically. We knew that late talkers and other children who were presenting with some early language
所以，在你被期望阅读和拼写单词之前，你是不会表现出阅读障碍的症状的，对吧？这说得通。所以在那个之前，我们能做的是发现风险。两三岁时的早期一般语言能力是另外两种风险的指标。即阅读障碍，以及发育性语言障碍的症状。因此，你可能会有更广泛、更普遍的语言问题。我们历史上就了解这一点。我们知道说话晚的孩子和其他表现出某些早期语言
problems or issues with potentially having problems later on with reading and spelling. Now once we get to be a little bit older, we can start looking at Prince Guild development. Is it hard for them to learn their letters and names? Is it hard for them to learn how to put letters and names to speak sounds? that they go with. That's another indicator. We can start to look now at something that language begets, which is our ability to do rhymes and hear the rhymes within words, to pull out the sounds within words. So once we get up to three and four and five, we can start to find those weaknesses. We also know that our ability to name objects and use that part of our language system is also a
问题或状况的儿童，在日后的阅读和拼写方面可能会潜在地遇到问题。现在，一旦我们年龄稍大一点，我们就可以开始关注印刷体技能的发展。他们学习字母和名称很难吗？他们学习将字母和名称与发音联系起来很难吗？这些是另一个指标。我们现在可以开始研究语言带来的能力，也就是我们押韵的能力、听出单词内部韵脚的能力、以及提取单词中语音的能力。因此，一旦我们到了三岁、四岁和五岁，我们就可以开始发现这些弱点。我们也知道，我们命名物体和使用语言系统这一部分的能力也是一个
reliable indicator of aspects of reading ability. So when we start to see these early indicators, what we're doing is we're increasing the risk indication, almost like we're doing a heart checkup every year at our annual physical, where we're asking these questions, and the more questions you answer yes to, and we take some blood work, and the more blood work says that you have risk, the higher risk indication is that you're at high risk for heart disease in the future.
可靠的阅读能力指标。因此，当我们开始看到这些早期指标时，我们实际上是在提高风险指标，这几乎就像我们在每年的常规体检中进行心脏检查一样，我们会询问这些问题，你对越多问题的回答是“是”，并且我们做一些血液检查，血液检查显示你有风险的次数越多，你就越有可能是未来患心脏病的极高风险人群。
Up until we're expecting kids to read and spell, we can find risk of dyslexia, which means that we can start to intervening in helping them develop, the language and print skills that they need to be successful later when we expect them to be able to read and spell words. You mentioned having a first degree relative with dyslexia. Do you have first degree relatives with diagnosed dyslexia?
在我们期望孩子阅读和拼写之前，我们可以发现阅读障碍的风险，这意味着我们可以开始进行干预，帮助他们培养日后在我们期望他们能够阅读和拼写单词时取得成功所需的语言和印刷技能。你提到过有一位患有阅读障碍的一级亲属。你是否有直系亲属被诊断出患有阅读障碍？
That's a great question, Kim. And I think it goes back to something you said earlier. We come from different generations. So that means that my parents likely were not in the context in their poor blue collar upbringings and where they were at. to be able to identify them with dyslexia. So a challenge that we don't have as much anymore since we have more awareness
这是一个很好的问题，金。我想这可以追溯到你刚才说的话。我们来自不同的代际。这意味着我的父母在他们贫穷的蓝领成长背景以及他们所处的环境中，很可能不具备能够被诊断出患有阅读障碍的条件。因此，由于我们现在有了更多认知，
and we've been identifying a lot more people is we're finding those. Did I have a parent who really didn't like to read and wasn't very good at it? Yes, I did. Did that parent have an identification of dyslexia? No, they did not. So I think that we have that generational factor. But I think today we have a much different situation
并且我们已经识别出了更多的人，我们不再面临那么大的挑战，我们正在发现这些情况。我有没有一个真的不喜欢阅读、而且在这方面很不擅长的父母？是的，我有。那个父母被诊断出患有阅读障碍了吗？没有，他们没有。所以我认为我们存在这种代际因素。但我认为今天我们的情况大不相同了
where it's more likely with awareness, which is really important. and I thank you for allowing me to have this space to talk about dyslexia, that it's more common to be able to say yes. So my son did have a first-degree relative that had dyslexia. Me. He also had an aunt, my sister, who had issues with reading and spelling words early in her life as well. So we knew, and I did early preventative work starting at birth with his language development
有了认知之后，这种情况更有可能被说出来，这真的很重要。感谢你给我这个空间来谈论阅读障碍，现在能够说“是的”变得更常见了。所以我的儿子确实有一位患有阅读障碍的一级亲属。我。他还有一个阿姨，也就是我的姐姐，在她生命早期也有阅读和拼写单词的问题。所以我们知道了，我在他一出生时就开始对他进行早期的预防性工作，针对他的语言发展
to set him up for success. Even with all that effort, we got to the end of first. and reading and spelling words was really, really hard for him, despite his enriched environment, despite having two college-educated parents in the home, despite being exceptional and doing very well on an IQ test this time around. You know, that generational difference between context is so important. You can see it so well on my story with my son. He aced the IQ test. He was exceptional on the IQ test. All of his language development in so many ways was okay, but it was still hard for him to learn and spell. So he got two years of a really intensive
为他的成功打下基础。即便付出了所有的努力，我们到了小学一年级结束时，阅读和拼写单词对他来说依然非常非常困难，尽管他拥有丰富的环境，尽管家里有两个受过大学教育的父母，尽管他这次智商测试表现优异且非常出色。你知道，背景上的代际差异是如此重要。从我和我儿子的故事中可以非常清楚地看出来。他的智商测试得了满分。他在智商测试中表现优异。他在很多方面的语言发展都还可以，但学习和拼写对他来说依然很难。因此，他接受了为期两年的真正密集、
structured literacy intervention that helped to set him up. He's still disfluent, which is often a common problem, and he also struggles with spelling still, which is often a lingering problem. But for parents who are listening, you don't have to feel guilty if you've done all that you can. You still, you know, you don't have the wherewithal to necessarily beat it. Exactly. I think that's really important. And some people have pushed to tight to get rid of dyslexia a term or the category. I think it's really important to note that the lingering lifelong impact for some of us are still there. I didn't get the intervention. I compensated. I'm called the compensated dyslexic. My spelling is really, really, really atrocious still. My ability
结构化的读写干预，这为他打下了基础。他现在说话仍然很不流利，这通常是一个常见的问题，而且他在拼写方面仍然很挣扎，这也是一个挥之不去的问题。但是对于正在收听的父母来说，如果你已经尽了最大努力，你不需要感到内疚。你仍然，你知道，你可能没有能力彻底克服它。完全正确。我认为这真的很重要。有些人一直在力促彻底取消阅读障碍这个术语或类别。我认为非常重要的一点是要指出，对我们中的一些人来说，那种挥之不去的终身影响仍然存在。我没有得到干预。我进行了补偿。我被称为“补偿型阅读障碍者”。我的拼写直到现在还是非常、非常、非常糟糕。我的能力
to read fluently is still really, really hard. So reading anything that's not within my area of study that I have a deep memory for and understand the structure of it really, really well is really challenging for me. So now that we have things like Audible and other services, I consume a lot of print through audio, which has been great for me because it means I can keep up with readings. But it doesn't mean that I want to read for pleasure because it isn't pleasurable for me to read, but I enjoy listening and reading. There's a few books that I'll read. I read a lot for work. So I think it's important for us not to get rid of at least this idea of dyslexia because the persistent challenges with spelling and writing are real, as well as the persistence was, the fluency is often
流利阅读仍然非常、非常困难。因此，阅读任何不属于我研究领域、我没有深刻记忆且对其结构没有非常深入理解的东西，对我来说都极具挑战性。所以现在我们有了 Audible 和其他类似的服务，我通过音频消费大量的印刷内容，这对我很不错，因为这意味着我可以跟上阅读进度。但这并不意味着我想为了消遣而阅读，因为阅读对我不具有消遣性，但我喜欢听和读。我会读一些书。我为了工作要读很多书。所以我认为我们不应该抛弃阅读障碍这个概念，因为拼写和写作方面的持续挑战是真实存在的，而且挥之不去的还有流畅度，这往往是
something that lingers, and that will create lifelong opportunities for us to overcome. Let's switch gears for a minute and talk about interventions. What are the kinds of interventions that are effective, that really work? And do most educators have access to these things? The answer is no to the last one. Most educators don't have access. to them, nor the training it takes to do them well, which is going to be developing knowledge of the English language and writing system, as well as supervision and how you deliver these. Not surprisingly, since I've highlighted the whole time that dyslexia is really this basic reading problem with reading and spelling words, that it's going to start with looking very much
一个挥之不去的问题，这将为我们创造终身需要克服的机会。让我们换个话题，花一分钟讨论一下干预措施。有哪些干预措施是有效的、真正起作用的？大多数教育工作者都能接触到这些方法吗？最后一个问题的答案是不。大多数教育工作者接触不到，也没有做好这些工作所需的培训，这包括培养对英语语言和书写系统的知识，以及关于如何实施这些方法的监督。毫不奇怪，既然我一直在强调阅读障碍本质上是阅读和拼写单词方面的基本阅读问题，那么它将首先非常类似于
like primary reading, where we're going to be teaching letters and sounds and how to put those together, how to read simple words. The challenge with English as a writing system is this is a very complex writing system, which means that our words also have other layers. It's not just about the phonics of sounding words out. It's also knowing that there's words that are going to have larger letter patterns in them that are going to go to a pronunciation. And it's not going to comply with this. A says a or A says A or A says all. A says five things. It's a really bloody thing. It also says ah. So the challenge is that it's not just that letters or even a couple of letters like diograph c h goes ch or triograph tc h goes ch it's even more complex than that. So the English
初级阅读，我们将教授字母和发音以及如何将它们组合在一起，如何阅读简单的单词。英语作为书写系统的挑战在于，这是一个非常复杂的书写系统，这意味着我们的单词还有其他层级。这不仅仅关乎拼读单词的自然拼读法。它还意味着有些单词内部有更大的字母模式，这些模式对应着特定的发音。它并不总是遵循“A 发 /æ/ 或 A 发 /eɪ/ 或 A 发 /ɔː/”这样的规则。A 发五种音。这真是个让人头疼的东西。它甚至还发 /ɑ/ 音。因此，挑战不仅在于字母，甚至不只是像字母组合 ch 发 /tʃ/，或者三字母组合 tch 发 /tʃ/ 这样，它甚至比这更复杂。所以英语
writing system of how we we take sound and put it into print is quite challenging. So for doing a really good version of dyslexia when you have kids that if you teach them the basic stuff they just don't automatically apply that to more complex word reading. Many of us will take more complex word instruction as well as meaning instruction. And it needs to be implemented in a way that gets us lots of practice reading words, reading words and sentences, reading words and text. And of course, the ultimate reason why we read is to understand what someone's trying to tell us. So we have to embed that within lots of opportunities for us to read and apply what we're learning to read, read words and then also spell words to understand text.
将声音转化为印刷体的书写系统是相当具有挑战性的。因此，当我们对患有阅读障碍的孩子进行真正高水平的干预时，如果你教他们基础知识，他们并不会自动将这些知识应用到更复杂的单词阅读中。我们中的许多人将需要更复杂的单词教学以及语义教学。并且它的实施方式需要让我们有大量练习阅读单词的机会，在句子中阅读单词，在文本中阅读单词。当然，我们阅读的终极原因是为了理解别人试图告诉我们什么。因此，我们必须将其融入大量的机会中，让我们去阅读并应用我们正在学习的知识来阅读，阅读单词，然后还要拼写单词以理解文本。
How can having dyslexia affect a person's mental health, especially when we're talking about children and teens in school settings? Well, this is really important in something that's had a lot of increased awareness now. We're actually redoing the definition of dyslexia out of the International Dyslexia Association. And one of the drivers for that was in the original definition that we had from IDA, from back in 2002, we would talk about secondary consequences. If you've highlighted, I've been talking about word reading and spelling. Accurately, efficient word reading, meaning we can read them quickly, and then text fluency,
患有阅读障碍会如何影响一个人的心理健康，特别是当我们谈论学校环境中的儿童和青少年时？嗯，这非常重要，并且现在这种认知度已经大大提高。我们实际上正在国际阅读障碍协会（International Dyslexia Association）的领导下重新定义阅读障碍。推动这一改变的原因之一是，在我们最初从 IDA 获得的、早在 2002 年的定义中，我们会谈到次要后果。正如你所强调的，我一直在谈论单词阅读和拼写。准确、高效的单词阅读，意味着我们可以快速阅读它们，然后是文本流畅度，
the ability to fluently read text with expression. We would highlight secondary consequences. If you can't read text, then do it well. It's probably hard to understand what someone's saying because you're spending so much of your time and resources and psychological energies trying to read the words. So by the time you get through, you've forgotten what the whole thing was about. Another secondary consequence is when we're not being exposed to print, we're not being exposed to the rich language and words that people are going to use.
即流利地、带有表现力地阅读文本的能力。我们会强调次要后果。如果你不能很好地阅读文本，那么理解别人的意思可能会很困难，因为你把大量的时间、资源和心理精力都花在了辨认单词上。因此，当你读完时，你已经忘了一整篇到底讲的是什么。另一个次要后果是，当我们没有接触印刷文本时，我们就没有接触到人们将要使用的丰富语言和词汇。
So our vocabulary can lag behind as well. Well, we had named those kind of academic areas of secondary consequences. What we now have a preponderance of evidence for is that mental health really tanks and those of us with dyslexia. We feel a lot of shame. We feel a lot of guilt. We don't feel good about ourself. So we have low self-esteem.
因此，我们的词汇量也会落后。好吧，我们已经命名了那些学术领域的次要后果。现在我们拥有大量证据表明，我们这些患有阅读障碍的人的心理健康确实会崩溃。我们感到非常羞耻。我们感到非常内疚。我们对自己的感觉不好。所以我们的自尊心很低。
Our ability to think that we're capable of doing things or what we call our self-efficacy is also impacted. And there's stigma associated with a label of disability, which in the public, you already highlighted, they often think means that we're not very smart, that we're incapable of doing anything more. So it's a real challenge. So what we've seen now is there's been multiple studies of studies. We call them meta-analyses where we go out and people look at 20, 30, 40, 50, 60 studies. When you look at people who have language-based learning differences, the two that have been studied the most are developmental language disability as well as dyslexia.
我们认为自己有能力做事情的能力，或者我们称之为自我效能感（self-efficacy），也受到了影响。残疾标签还伴随着一种污名化，正如公众所认为的那样，你刚才已经强调过了，他们通常认为这意味着我们不够聪明，没有能力做更多的事情。所以这是一个真正的挑战。因此我们现在看到的是，已经有了多项针对研究的研究。我们称之为元分析（meta-analyses），即我们去查阅资料，人们会研究 20、30、40、50、60 项研究。当你审视那些有基于语言的学习差异的人时，研究最多的两个是发育性语言障碍以及阅读障碍。
We have an increased prevalence of depression and anxiety in particular. So we're a lot more likely to have major depression. We're also much more likely to have issues of anxiety. Now, those are what we call internalizing conditions. We internalize those. We bring those in. We fill them inside of us about how we feel, how we process the world, how we process ourselves. There's also evidence that we have increased externalizing problems,
我们发现抑郁症和焦虑症的发病率尤其高。因此，我们患严重抑郁症的可能性要大得多。我们患焦虑症问题的可能性也大得多。现在，这些就是我们所说的内化病症。我们将这些情绪内化。我们将它们带入内心。我们把它们充满内心，关于我们的感受、我们如何处理世界、我们如何处理自己。还有证据表明，我们的外化问题有所增加，
which is to be a conduct problem, to be a behavioral problem, to be a problem in school, to be a problem in life, to get wrapped up in the penal system and be winding up in prison, for example. There's also evidence for that. But the reason for that seems to be the fact that when you come in and experience the chronic stress of going to school every single day from early in childhood and not having the ability to do what your peers do, to be labeled as stupid, to be labeled as dumb, to be laughed at, to be heckled, to read in front of a class. It's not like trauma with a big T, but it is what we call chronic stress. Yeah.
也就是行为问题，行为习惯问题，学校里的问题，生活中的问题，卷入司法体系并最终进监狱，例如。也有证据证明这一点。但其中的原因似乎在于，当你走进学校，从童年早期开始，每天都要去上学，却无法做到同龄人能做的事，被贴上愚蠢的标签，被贴上笨拙的标签，被嘲笑，被起哄，在全班面前朗读，从而经历慢性压力。这不像那种带有大写T的创伤，但它正是我们所说的慢性压力。是的。
There's a popular narrative that dyslexia comes with special gifts, like creativity or out-of-the-box thinking. What does the research say on that front? Well, the research is incomplete and ongoing. However, the research that's been done to date would say that this idea that there's like four or five superpowers that dyslexic have is just not kind of panning out for us right now, take creativity. There's been two recent studies of studies, meta-analyses, that show that individual
有一个流行的说法，认为读写障碍伴随着特殊的天赋，比如创造力或跳出常规的思维。在这方面，研究是怎么说的？嗯，研究还不完整且正在进行中。然而，迄今为止完成的研究会表明，这种认为读写障碍者拥有四五种超能力的观点，目前对我们来说根本行不通，以创造力为例。最近有两项针对多项研究的综合研究（即元分析），它们表明个体
of dyslexia on measures of creativity aren't showing any kind of ability that's any greater than just like the general population. Visual spatial processing is also sought to be one of those. The anecdote that's often given is to say that, oh, people who are astrophysicists over-indexed for people with dyslexia. And they would use that anecdotal evidence or that kind of constrained way of saying that, oh, this must be a superpower. Well, when you look at objective measures of visual spatial processing and you pull those research studies together and look at them in a meta-analysis, we don't see evidence that we have increased visual spatial processing. If I'm not mistaken when I did the review and published it on this, we actually saw that there might be evidence of a little bit lower performance in some of the studies for those of us with dyslexia.
在创造力测量上的读写障碍表现，并没有表现出任何比普通人群更强或更高的能力。视觉空间处理也被认为是其中之一。经常有人举出的轶事是，说天体物理学家中读写障碍者的比例过高。他们会使用这种轶事证据，或者这种受限的方式来说，哦，这一定是一种超能力。然而，当你查看视觉空间处理的客观测量指标，并将这些研究整合在一起并在元分析中观察它们时，我们没有看到证据表明我们的视觉空间处理能力有所增强。如果我在做综述并发表相关文章时没有记错的话，我们实际上在一些研究中看到，对于我们这些有读写障碍的人来说，表现可能还有点偏低。
But that washes out. It's kind of like no difference. The entrepreneurism is a really interesting one. And I was listening to David and Goliath recently from Malcolm Gladwell. And he features as one of the underdog stories, those of us with dyslexia. It's a really compelling narrative to say that we have superpowers. And Malcolm Gladwell definitely highlights this. The challenge is that the methodology that's been used from a psychological science perspective on the entrepreneur research is less than optimal. And we're not really doing it well. Does it mean that the case studies that we have, like a Steve Jobs, for example, or Richard Branson, aren't like high achieving people who identify with dyslexia who also have shown that they have these great strengths and gifts? That's definitely true. It can definitely also be role models for certain people. So that one is one that's kind of like more research is needed, especially with better methodology. The artistic pieces, too, was often one. The great artist of the world are thought to be dyslexic. So here's the challenge with that is.
但这最终被抵消了。这有点像没有区别。创业精神是一个非常有趣的话题。我最近在听马尔科姆·格拉德威尔的《大卫与歌利亚》。他在书中将我们这些患有读写障碍的人作为失败者逆袭的故事之一进行特色报道。认为我们拥有超能力的说法是一个非常引人入胜的叙事。马尔科姆·格拉德威尔绝对强调了这一点。但面临的挑战是，从心理科学的角度来看，创业研究中使用的方差和方法论远非最佳。我们并没有真正把它做好。这是否意味着我们拥有的案例研究，例如史蒂夫·乔布斯或理查德·布兰森，不是那些认同读写障碍且表现出这些巨大优势和天赋的高成就者？这绝对是真的。它绝对也可以成为某些人的榜样。所以这一点有点像需要更多研究，特别是需要更好的方法论。艺术方面也经常是一个话题。世界上伟大的艺术家被认为是读写障碍者。所以这里面面临的挑战是，
And you did highlight that. And I'm not a clinical psychologist. I'm a psychological scientist. And I was trained historically in what we call social cognitive as well as developmental cognitive perspectives. And a really important piece out of that research literature is the idea of stereotypes. So the thing about a stereotype is that's when we paint a group of people with a limited set of traits or abilities or qualities that is not true of all.
你也强调了这一点。我不是临床心理学家。我是一名心理科学工作者。我曾在我们所说的社会认知以及发展认知视角方面接受过历史训练。该研究文献中一个非常重要的部分是关于刻板印象的概念。因此，刻板印象的事情在于，它是当我们用一组有限的特征、能力或品质来描绘一群人时，这并非适用于所有人，
of them uniformly, but might be true of a few of them selectively. We normally think about these as negative. We also have positive stereotypes. And so the way that I think about the gift of dyslexia narrative is it's actually told typically in society is that when we limit the ability for us to be exceptional to does four or five things that we say is going to be true of all of us, that's by definition of positive stereotype. And stereotypes and even positive stereotypes are, are also a pathway to negative thoughts about oneself. Because what does it mean? Like when I was doing one of my first brain imaging studies and a little girl started crying
而是有选择性地适用于其中一小部分人。我们通常认为这些是负面的。我们也有正面的刻板印象。因此，我如何看待读写障碍天赋的叙事方式，通常在社会上是这样讲述的：当我们把我们成为杰出人物的能力限制在我们所说适用于我们所有人的四五件事上时，根据定义，这就是一种正面刻板印象。而刻板印象，甚至是正面的刻板印象，也是通往对自己产生负面想法的途径。因为这意味着什么？就像我在做我的第一个大脑成像研究时，一个小女孩开始哭泣，
when she was in the mock scanner. A mock scanner is a mock-up of an MRI scanner. I had one of my assistants in there taking this little girl to the procedures. I was sitting with the mother in the waiting room. We could watch what was happening through a window and we were talking about it. And I turned to the mother and says, we have to stop the experiment. And she says, why? I said, well, she's crying. And this isn't about what we want as adults. It's what's best for her and her psychological well-being. Like, this is clearly an adverse situation for her.
当她还在模拟扫描仪里的时候。模拟扫描仪是MRI扫描仪的模型。我让我的一个助手在里面带着这个小女孩熟悉流程。我和孩子的母亲坐在候诊室里。我们可以通过窗户看到发生了什么，我们在讨论这件事。我转向母亲说，我们必须停止实验。她说，为什么？我说，嗯，她在哭。这无关我们作为成年人的意愿，而是对她和她的心理健康最有利的事情。听着，对她来说这显然是一个逆境。
She said, give her a second. And the little girl stopped crying. And then she started smiling. And then she got right back into the mock scanner. And she went on it. She says, well, here's the thing about her is. Since she's been identified and diagnosed with dyslexia, she's also learned that dyslexia is supposed to be a superpower. and she hasn't found her superpower yet because she's not good at art. She doesn't want to go off and be a business woman. She's not really great with creative thinking and out-of-the-box thinking. And so all these stereotypic things that she was supposed to be good at, she was good at none of them.
她说，给她一秒钟。然后小女孩停止了哭泣。接着她开始微笑了。然后她直接回到了模拟扫描仪里。她继续进行了。她说，关于她，情况是这样的：自从她被识别并诊断出患有读写障碍以来，她还了解到读写障碍应该是一种超能力。但她还没有找到她的超能力，因为她不擅长艺术。她不想去当女商人。她真的不擅长创造性思维和跳出常规的思维。所以所有这些她本该擅长的刻板印象的事情，她一件也不擅长。
But I would say that she was the bravest little person I knew. She was willing to do what with grown servicemen and women who were coming in from my DOD-funded research into the same mock scanner, would crawl out of the scanner, would be hyperventilating, would be so afraid to do. There were these grown men and women who went into combat, and there was this little girl who would fearlessly get into that scanner, and why she was crying wasn't out of fear of being in there or doing the unknown. It was because she was afraid that she wasn't a good dyslexic.
但我会说，她是我认识的最勇敢的小不点。她愿意做那些从我国防部资助的研究中来到同一个模拟扫描仪里的成年军人都不敢做的事——他们会从扫描仪里爬出来，会过度通气，会害怕得要命。有那些去过战场的高大威猛的成年男女，而这个小女孩却无所畏惧地钻进那个扫描仪里，她哭泣的原因不是因为害怕呆在里面或面对未知。而是因为她害怕自己不是一个合格的读写障碍者。
Wow, that's tough. That's tough, right? That's the definition of a stereotype right there. And I saw as a junior faculty the negative impact on this precious girl who was fearless, And we often joked, it was like, if they showed up with one teddy bear or stuffy, then we thought we'd get them through the scanner because, you know, it's scary to go into an MRI. If they showed up with two stuffies, it took two stuffies to get out the door that day to come and do the research. We knew that we were going to have to stop the study. It wasn't going to work.
哇，这太艰难了。这太艰难了，对吧？这就是刻板印象的定义。作为一名年轻的教职员工，我看到了这对于这个无所畏惧的珍贵女孩所造成的负面影响。我们经常开玩笑说，如果他们带着一只泰迪熊或毛绒玩具出现，那么我们就认为能让他们顺利完成扫描，因为你知道，做核磁共振是挺吓人的。如果他们带着两个毛绒玩具出现，那天得用两个毛绒玩具才能把他们劝出门来做研究。我们就知道我们得停止研究了。这行不通。
But she was fearless, this little girl. It took no stuffies for her to be there. You know, her dad or mom didn't have to go into the scanner bay with her and hold her foot for her to be safe or comfortable in there. Well, just to wrap up. What's next for you? What are you working on now? Oh, that's a great question. I think what I'm working on now really is the translation of psychological science and the science of reading and the science of learning out there into the world to educators. And in particular, a role that me and some others play is trying to think about how do we take all these policy that we have across the United States?
但她无所畏惧，这个小女孩。她不需要任何毛绒玩具就能待在那里。你知道，她的爸爸妈妈不需要跟她一起进扫描室，握着她的脚来让她在里面感到安全或舒适。好了，最后总结一下。你接下来有什么打算？你现在在忙什么？哦，这是一个好问题。我想我现在正在做的事情，实际上是将心理科学、阅读科学以及学习科学转化并带到世界各地，传授给教育工作者。特别是，我和其他人扮演的一个角色是，试着思考我们如何整合全美各地的所有这些政策？
How do we recalibrate them to do more effective screening, to do early risk identification early, maybe. even in preschool with some states that I'm working with, using more broad language screens. So we can look at their greater risk indicators, pull them into early intervention, and actually help the kids who have less susceptibility, have better outcomes, and then freeing up the resources when we get to second, third, fourth, and fifth grade to give the more intensive intervention to those who we couldn't identify earlier and help to lessen their outcomes later on. So I'm really working in this space of translation and communication, as well as policy advocacy, not myself, but working with the advocates and the state houses around the country to help them
我们如何重新调整它们以进行更有效的筛查，尽早进行早期风险识别，也许在某些我正在合作的州，甚至在学前班阶段就使用更广泛的语言筛查。这样我们就可以查看他们更大的风险指标，将他们纳入早期干预，并真正帮助那些易感性较低的孩子取得更好的成果，然后在我们进入二年级、三年级、四年级和五年级时释放资源，为那些我们无法提早识别的人提供更密集的干预，并帮助减少他们日后的不良结果。所以我真的在从事这种转化和沟通，以及政策倡导的空间，不是我自己去，而是与全美各地的倡导者和州议会合作，帮助他们
reframe and rethink the dyslexia legislation. And how do we be doing something more expansive? You know, we don't do well as screen for language. And when we don't screen for language, that means that a lot of kids who are going to struggle with reading comprehension who have a developmental language disability. They won't be identified. There's a real need for us to think about how we bring our screening practices that have been motivated by legislation over the past 10 years into a unified system that's screening for language risk, that's identifying kids who are going to struggle with reading comprehension as well as reading the words and get the supports that they all need in there and place. That's what I'm working on.
重新构建和思考读写障碍立法。我们该如何做一些更具包容性的事情？你知道，我们在语言筛查方面做得并不好。当我们不进行语言筛查时，这意味着许多将要在阅读理解方面苦苦挣扎、患有发展性语言障碍的孩子将无法被识别。我们迫切需要思考如何将过去十年立法推动的筛查实践，纳入到一个统一的系统中，这个系统既筛查语言风险，识别那些在阅读理解以及认字方面会苦苦挣扎的孩子，并让他们在适当的地方获得所需的所有支持。这就是我正在做的事情。
Well, that sounds really important. And I want to thank you. This has been great information. Thank you not only for talking to me, but for sharing your own journey. Well, Kim, thank you so much for helping to raise awareness. I feel so honored to be able to share this in this space. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.
嗯，听起来真的很重要。我要谢谢你。这些信息太棒了。不仅感谢你与我交谈，还感谢你分享你自己的心路历程。凯姆，非常感谢你帮助提高公众意识。我很荣幸能够在这个平台上分享这些。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学之声》以前的单集，
Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wyner. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在苹果、声田、优兔或任何你收听播客的地方找到。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·怀纳制作。感谢收听美国心理学会节目。我是凯姆·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任何句子即可发表评论。